Літак із Москви приземлився в Борисполі.
35 українських бранців Кремля повернулися на батьківщину
та побачилися з родичами.
Хтось - уперше за 9 місяців, а хтось – і за всі 5 років.
Першими виходять військовополонені моряки.
Не всі вони хочуть спілкуватися з пресою.
Перепрошують, що забагато емоцій.
Один із наймолодших звільнених українців -
- 20-річний В'ячеслав Зінченко -
служив старшим матросом на катері "Нікополь".
Перші його слова - слова подяки всім,
хто підтримував його і інших моряків, хто писав листи.
Він вибачається що, можливо, не всім відповів.
Для нього останні кілька днів були, мабуть, найскладнішими в житті.
- Інформація постійно змінювалася.
Казали, що обмін зривається. Тому я просто жив.
Буквально тиждень… 28-го і 29-го серпня – один з найскладніших періодів.
Я і вночі не міг спати. І слава Богу, що не сказали...
Я дізнався о 4-й ранку, що ми збираємо речі і їдемо.
Звичайно, час до літака тягнувся дуже довго.
Його мати Елеонора Новак назвала обмін найшвидшим із усіх,
які до сьогодні відбувалися між Україною і Росією.
Поки що вона не бажає думати ані про умови обміну,
ані чому це сталося саме сьогодні.
Її цікавить майбутнє сина.
- Найближчим часом він хоче вступати,
бо минулоріч не встиг вступив в вище мореходне...
Ну і далі хоче продовжувати службу.
Окрім моряків, Росія віддала і політв’язнів.
Чи погодиться Москва звільнити їх усіх
та чи не зірвуться домовленості в останній момент,
було головною інтригою обміну.
До тата-журналіста агентства Укрінформ Романа Сущенка,
якого затримали в Росії, звинуватили у шпигунстві
та засудили до 12 років суворого режиму,
першим біжить його син.
На питання про перше бажання на рідній землі Сущенко відповідає:
- Напевно, поїв  би кавунів.
- Кавунів? Херсонських? Чи миколаївських?
- Будь-яких.
- Солодких.
А якщо серйозно, то Сущенко та його дружина
зізнаються, що до останнього не вірили в те,
що їм вдасться побачитися на волі.
- 7 вересня - для моєї родини особливий день.
Українська держава повернула нас додому.
Це є незаперечний факт.
Я чітко розумію, що в цьому процесі
брала участь велика кількість людей.
Це титанічні зусилля, тому моя родина щиро дякує всім за це.
Політв'язню Миколі Карпюку теж поки не віриться,
що він дихає українським повітрям.
У Росії його засудили до 22 років ув’язнення.
Відсидів 3 роки. Він каже, поки взагалі не усвідомлює,
як змінилася Україна за той час, який він провів за ґратами в Росії:
нова влада і зовсім інша, ніж усі попередні.
- Коли я відкрив фото своєю мовою,
я просто просяяв від щастя.
Ви до кінця не усвідомлюєте, яка це цінність -
вільні люди вільної країни.
На відміну від інших звільнених, Микола Карпюк
відверто розповідає, як до нього ставилися в російській в’язниці.
Каже, що катували, але найболючіше було чути, як страждають інші.
- Когось виводять
і починають накривати йому голову
целофановим кульком
і скрегіт скотчу.
Скотчем перемотують, щоб людина нічого не бачила.
Людину вивозять на тортури.
А потім його привозять... у сусідню камеру.
Цей крик мєнта:
На калєні! Нє спать!
А той бідолаха стогне
і проситься: дайте мені папір, я напишу все, що від мене...
Дайте мені поспати просто.
Ось це найстрашніше.
21-норічного українського студента Павла Гриба
у 2017-му силою вивезли з Білорусі в Росію
і звинуватили в підготовці теракту,
за що російський суд засудив його до 6 років ув’язнення.
Щойно прилетівши до Києва, Павло
багато розповідає про тих, кого, на відміну від нього,
досі утримують на території Росії чи то окупованого Донбасу.
- Там сидять дуже багато - 150 десь чоловік.
Скільки нас? 35 десь, так?
Ось, визволили моряків, так,
але як буде з іншими при цьому?
Треба займатися, звичайно.
Займатися не тільки так, як ми зараз займаємося,
а більш професійно.
Адвокат українських моряків Микола Полозов вважає:
цей великий обмін міг би не відбутися,
якби не рішення морського трибуналу,
яке зобов’язало Росію повернути моряків Україні.
Росія, розповідає Полозов, не хотіла напряму
виконувати це рішення, тому додала до моряків і політв’язнів.
До того ж, цього разу вдалося домовитися
щодо статусу утримуваних в Росії і в Україні,
адже Москва не хотіла нікого віддавати в якості полонених.
- На цей момент українські моряки
є обвинуваченими у кримінальній справі в Росії
і звільнені з-під варти під особисте зобов’язання
омбудсмена Людмили Денисової.
Справа проти них в Росії не закрита, вона триває.
Питання участі чи неучасті моряків
у наступних судових чи не судових діях,
найімовірніше, буде вирішуватися під час окремих перемовин.
Що стосується інших політв’язнів, то мені відомо,
що щодо до них видали накази про помилування.
Мало хто в Україні до останнього вірив, що Кремль
поверне Олега Сенцова і активіста Олександра Кольченка.
Їх обох звинувачували у плануванні теракту в Криму.
Кольченко, як і Сенцов, провів у російських в’язницях майже 5 років.
Каже: він також до останнього не вірив, що обмін таки відбудеться.
- Я вже спокійно все сприймав.
Головне, щоб не кудись в Омськ.
Олександр знає, що всі бранці Кремля
пройдуть ретельне медичне обстеження
та курс реабілітації в державній клініці.
А потім він почне думати про навчання
в Таврійському національному університеті.
(питання за кадром: Ким будете?)
- Агентом із організації туризму.
Олександр та інші звільнені поки утримуються від відповіді про те,
на кого їх обміняли та чому це вдалося зробити
вже за нового президента України Володимира Зеленського.
Деякі з колишніх полонених сподіваються, що
наступним кроком стане повернення понад двохсот українців
із підвалів Донецька та Луганська.
А Зеленський заявив, що нинішній обмін
був лише першим етапом. Наступним має стати
звільнення затриманих у Росії кримських татар.